so even this guy's given advice on how
to avoid politics at Thanksgiving if you
are going home and you know getting
nervous about arguing with you mommy
your dad or your onto your uncle
I think the point to be made is that
what we are fighting for the values that
we are fighting for are really not new
values and I think people if you talk to
them understand that or they're gonna
have a hard time explaining why it is ok
for three people to own more wealth than
the bottom half of America and why some
of these corporations pay nothing in
taxes so you see that he said let's
unify then he slams the rich we're
different here at the five we're not
interested in prolonging debate only and
ending it with a quick knockout so
number one let's start with economic
inequality did you know 70% of rich
Americans grew up in lower-income
households
yep they moved up wealth not only leaves
the wealthy after generations it shifts
to the poor I mean how else could Bernie
afford so many homes he moved up the
ladder he claims didn't exist when the
only thing he could really run is a
stalking you want to talk impeachment
fine good luck impeaching Trump for
doing his job which is uncovering
corruption if satisfying the public
interest helps is interest so what quid
pro quo that's life it'd be great to get
something for nothing but that involves
killing bartering beats bombings unless
it's Isis the orange man finished them
off and then let the dog have the last
laugh how about climate change well how
about it what's your position on China
seeing as it's the world's worst fossil
fuel polluter oh I forgot China's guck
not America guess they get a pass but
I'll listen to Bill Gates who says
nuclear is a vital energy source
especially if you want to cut out carbon
emissions Donald Trump yeah he's bad we
have lowest unemployment of decades
blacks women Hispanics are doing better
under Trump than Obama and bodies aren't
coming home in coffins so what's your
alternative Liz Bernie Joe blew me who's
gonna sponsor that debate Life Alert
here's what Trump tweeted today the
media described it as doctored Thank You
Gina geniuses
we're so gonna miss him when he's gone
in 2024 fact is Trump's changed politics
you have leftist like Matt Taibbi
calling out the phony dossier and
Republicans like this nut mocking black
conservatives Trump's rearranged the
place settings at America's table left
is right right is left it's crumbling so
sit back enjoy the meal maybe this year
I'll give to sit with the grown-ups I
think we need better topics to talk
about I've come up with a few I'm gonna
start with you Juan mash or mashed
potatoes I say mash what yes what's the
difference there no people say mashed
potatoes other people say mashed
potatoes I think that's two extra
letters you don't need it's the same on
the plate right pass the mash or the
mashed mashed yeah right grammatically
correct she I learned bash you've got a
young age and I've stayed at that is
that a West Coast thing I don't know
what mast I'm from that same West Coast
et mashed dance is the mashed potato not
mashed wait I think this is this is why
we debate politics Juan because that
didn't work I love that it took me a
second realize when you said the dance
that's the one with the gut the
Halloween that's a month that's the
monster yeah no excuse because even
Texans say mash well I'm haven't even
gotten to you were at the kids table
don't do it I am Lawrence has very
strong feelings on who is a real country
singer and who isn't a real country
singer right Dana he has very strong
feelings he shared with me in the green
room we're having a big debate okay our
purposes I used to didn't like country
Travis Tritt brought me on country I
like the soulful country Chris Stapleton
those type of people and this one guy
the old country Toby Keith is there a
real country singer that's
he said he likes Chris Stapleton which I
agree is cool he said I said what about
Toby Keith and I started playing him
courtesy of the red white and blue and
he said that's horrible that's not real
I just like the red white and blue is
horrible it was horrible I thought it
was very depressing because if you're
sitting there having this discussion I
think I'm gonna be like I don't know
anything up on you at a real
Thanksgiving dinner what if I said like
little knives X which I think it's the
song of the year yeah well I mean
actually the song of the year really we
all know or set up about politics that
is so true what Emily do you ever do
have spirited debates or what do you
talk about when you're over Thanksgiving
we talk about everything I grew up
having dinner with my whole family every
night and it was always about
conversation and connection and I was I
feel like that's why I love storytelling
so much I love listening to stories I
love listening to people's opinions and
and I learned so much I feel like it was
a history lesson every night too I
learned about my family's traditions and
my culture it was awesome and I know
part of this is like what is our advice
for when you delve into politics and if
you feel differently with your family
members and for me it's just remembering
that it's your loved one that you're
talking about with and you don't love
them I mean to keep that in mind right I
was bright I love my loved ones but I'm
still gonna kick their tail in a debate
I'm sorry I don't come up to a fight
because I never started I never started
talking I do this for a living and I
want to just have a chill okay okay -
Tom shall lose point on your show
earlier your Thanksgiving isn't a talk
show right right so you're supposed to
pop like it's not like that's what we're
trying to like exactly so everybody
should just chill out and talk about
other I don't think a show about
politics like I'd rather have a debate
about religion oh yes
really want to debate Lawrence more
about country music but I think burn it
so Bernie's point is interesting right
because Bernie said we should talk about
values and the common values and that's
what really comes together but but wait
a minute he's when he says that three
people owned more have more wealth than
half their countries right but let's not
bring it up because I love you auntie I
don't wanna you know or when Bernie says
hey how can it be that these big
corporations pay no taxes and you pay
taxes I and you know what uncle okay
let's go out to the rich people let's go
after that this despite you may have
been poor your entire life and you
finally get a little money and they want
to take you for everything that you got
you're Michael I'm saying he passed me
the turkey line I just met by the way
Lawrence is that right Obama only sent
sheets and pillows to the Ukrainians oh
my god and so I just proved it on this
show it's always the Liberals at the dog
whining cry yeah but you know what Greg
Greg told me drink Juan do you feel at
this table when we disagree do you feel
like we have fundamentally the same
values and the question is really
something like who is going to pay for
it or how to get there but you feel like
fundamentally we agree on values oh yeah
I mean it's for me this is really
interesting question because I think
Trump really is a poll right I think we
can agree that people get polarized but
the reality is what Bernie said most of
us have shared values about love of this
country about wanting our children to do
better about belief in the notion of
neighbors helping neighbors I don't
think there's a big argument no I hate
my neighbor Island and you like mocking
Dana Perino
have some alone time yet well no I've
been told not to talk about I've never
talked about politics but we're having
guests who who have issues with thumb
shorted things that I do for a living so
I will stay and I would like listen to
music and get drunk that's the thing I
have to speak to Rafi sometime just
remember that people love to talk about
themselves and share so you should use
just ask them about themselves like ask
say you know tell me tell me but like
tell me you know get to know about time
to listen to that stuff you know we're
only on the planet for why I don't care
except for you Emily I care about you
I'm supposed to say that